[Música]
cuando nacemos nacemos con muchas
características una de ellas es una suma
de capacidades
sin embargo cuando morimos
muchas de estas capacidades se han
perdido pero no porque desaparezcan
simplemente porque hemos olvidado que
las tenemos
recordemos cuando somos niños nada nos
impide ser el mejor del equipo ser el
mejor pintor
ser el deporte el mejor policía
imaginemos un salón de un kindergarten
niños entre 3 y 4 años sentados en mesas
de colores
la maestra les ha dado una tarea
y realizar un dibujo de su madre
todos y cada uno de ellos contra ganados
ninguno duda de la calidad de su trabajo
cada uno a su turno muestra la maestra
muy orgulloso el dibujo realizado
si avanzamos 15 años y ahora tenemos al
mismo grupo de niños en un primer curso
de universidad
el profesor realizó una pregunta
casi todos están seguros de conocer la
respuesta
pero ahora
todos dudan de levantar la mano
que ha cambiado
que cambia en nosotros desde que somos
pequeños y no tenemos dudas de nuestras
capacidades
hasta el momento en que uno fuere
y muere muchas veces llenos de dudas
recuerdo que cuando tenía cinco años
me encontraba junto a mi padre en la
dirección de una escuela
mi padre conversaba con el director de
esta escuela solicitando que yo sea
admitido puesto que habíamos llegado
tarde al proceso de inscripción
ante la reactiva del director mi padre
insistía y alegaba que yo no iba a dar
problemas que sería un buen muchacho
inclusive aseguraba que sería el mejor
de la clase
al escucharlo yo pequeño no tenía
ninguna duda de que sería así
por una autoconfianza simplemente porque
si mi padre creía en mí yo daba por
sentado que aquello ocurriría
desde entonces hasta el último día de mi
presencia en el colegio las
calificaciones no fueron un problema se
había cumplido casi como había dicho mi
padre
una juventud más bien una adolescencia
en la que todas las actividades
terminaban exitosas con cursos de teatro
ganados con cursos de danza ganados pero
en base a que en base a esfuerzo en base
a perseverancia
el problema es que a medida que crecemos
el esfuerzo y la perseverancia empiezan
a agotarse porque
porque mientras más uno se compromete
con las actividades mientras más van
pasando los años esta confianza este
trabajar día a día requiere de mayor
esfuerzo mayor esfuerzo mayor compromiso
mayor compromiso mayores horas de
trabajo
y empezamos a entrar en una rueda de
nunca acabar
un día mientras realizaba una prueba
para seleccionar el representante del
colegio en una actividad extracurricular
pasa por mi cabeza la idea
y no esforzarme más
porque no esforzarme porque cuando uno
se esfuerza y entra en una actividad es
muy posible que llegue el fracaso el
error
si uno no participa nunca va a errar
y no es dar es algo que de alguna manera
da una satisfacción pero una
satisfacción pobre pero satisfacción al
fin verdad
nunca nos va a dar la verdadera
satisfacción pero podemos entrar
nuevamente en un vórtice de encontrar
falsa satisfacción y no fallar
a partir de entonces en cada prueba yo
decidía no es mirarme para no ser
juzgado
si yo repito no participaba no era
juzgado nunca estaba
las personas generalmente
a lo largo de nuestra vida desde niños
empezamos a ser juzgados por nosotros
nuestros padres nuestros maestros
nuestros amigos
aquel que al inicio era el gran pintor
ante un comentario equivocado de un
profesor decide olvidar el pintor que
está adentro aquel que era un gran
jugador en el momento en que él no es
seleccionado por los compañeros de
escuela decide borrar al gran jugador
y poco a poco vamos eliminando todas
aquellas actividades en las cuales hemos
sido juzgados con un resultado negativo
en mi caso inició una actividad
universitaria del todo diferente de mi
carrera en colegio
las calificaciones rojas no eran una
novedad en mi registro
ir a segundas instancias ya era algo
esperado
el tomar una nueva asignatura con poca o
ninguna esperanza de sacar la máxima
calificación ya se había convertido en
parte de la rutina
con los años obviamente había olvidado
había escondido todo aquello que antes
para mí era
esto es lo que nos pasa generalmente
cuando observamos a los alumnos aquellos
que como yo se dedican a la docencia
en la actualidad tengo a mi cargo un
curso de prácticamente último año de
universidad
en una carrera en la cual los niveles de
exigencia para el ingreso son muy altos
las estadísticas dicen que los
estudiantes que veo sentados todos los
miércoles en la universidad han sido uno
de 10 postulantes a esa plaza en esa
carrera
por lo tanto desde el punto desde el
punto de vista teórico
yo tengo una clase espectacular
pero cuando vemos los resultados
recuerdo mi experiencia universitaria
muchos de ellos han perdido a través de
los años la capacidad de confiar
muchos de ellos cuando se hace una
pregunta ya no se esfuerzan siquiera en
pensar en la respuesta
qué ha ocurrido en el camino nuevamente
ellos han empezado a borrar han empezado
a atrapar cualidades características que
solamente cinco años los distinguían de
la masa como los mejores de los mejores
en el 10% del 100% que ahora lo han
olvidado
a lo largo de la universidad viendo a mi
historia esa fue la rutina
debo mencionar que reprobó
una asignatura en la cual ahora soy
especialista
se da también la vida un cambio inverso
un punto de inflexión
cuando alguna persona observa en
nosotros aquella cualidad que nosotros
mismos no podemos ver
tenemos estudiantes formidables
en nuestras universidades tenemos
personas que realizan trabajos ya sea
trabajos prácticos trabajos de
investigación cuyos resultados van más
allá del promedio que sin embargo ellos
mismos dudan de la calidad de estos
resultados
es por eso que a lo largo de los años
nosotros debemos tratar de buscar dentro
de nosotros mismos aquello que hemos
atrapado aquellas cualidades que hemos
borrado
generalmente en el caso de mis
estudiantes refiero que tal vez la
universidad debería darles un
certificado en el cual diga que ellos
pertenecen a ese 10% seleccionado a ese
10% de la élite en aquello que ellos
alguna vez decidieron realizar
porque porque todos tenemos días malos
todos tenemos fracasos
el error lo decía es parte de la vida
simplemente que cuando somos pequeños
nos enseñan a quedar es malo y que
vencer es bueno dejar y vencer son dos
cosas parte de la vida
así que lo único que tenemos que hacer
en los momentos en los que nos sintamos
derrotados es recordar aquellas metas
que nosotros ya hemos cumplido
en casa
a veces llego muy tarde muy cansado y
una vez más lo digo derrotado sin
embargo frente al escritorio tengo un
cuadro enmarcado uno de los logros
personales
no importa cual
la idea es que cada que me sienta
derrotado yo pueda ver que alguna vez he
alcanzado aquellas metas y que no debo
olvidar que algún día nací con todas las
oportunidades en la vida
de la misma manera yo invito a todos
ustedes a tener un cuadro ya sea un
cuadro imaginario o ya sea un cuadro
físico
frente a sus escritorios frente a sus
habitaciones en sus dormitorios pero un
cuadro que toca a ustedes rellenar
los méritos en la vida no son méritos
académicos los méritos no son solamente
méritos deportivos los méritos desde el
más pequeño hasta el más grande lo único
que nos permiten es a no olvidar que
algún día cumplimos nuestras metas toca
ustedes decidir que van a poner en cada
uno de sus cuadros de su vida y no
llegar al último día de esta vida
y recordar que han olvidado han
encerrado muchas de esas capacidades por
la que moss
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]